you got to throw it in like that what's
up GQ anthony mackie these are my
essentials
my most important essential is my trusty
iPhone six-plus everything since the six
plus has been a disaster so I will
always have this phone
I don't update I don't do anything to it
it always works crack screen I don't
care take a little bit of packing tape
put over it and start over
well the six plus is great because it
was the first one that was the big phone
so it was obnoxiously bigger than all
the other phones so it has a lot of
programming and data on it and I had the
big one like the 64 mega gigawatts or
whatever it was and I put all this music
on it so I have stuff that I can't find
anywhere else
you know like push babies I got gravity
on there can't blow first album on there
you can't find that stuff on a music
streaming websites now it's mine look
come on man
bust a rhyme extinction-level event you
can't I got stuff on here you cannot
find and it's quite a nice case it's
like snakeskin but it's leather
[Music]
I am a avid golf player I play golf
often about two to three times a week
this is my trusty 4 iron it's a great
clubs Forge gives you extra little
palpable distance I love this club
because if it's a par 5 I can make the
green in two because this is about my to
25 to 30 Club you have 300 off the tee
you go yeah I don't want to lay up and
go for it
and when I feel real arrogant is when I
play golf I go for it all the time
no it's a toss-up between Don Cheadle
and Sam Jackson now I'm not gonna say
what the two of them have in common
other than being old black dudes and
rich but both of them are very good
golfers so that's how you know they rich
I'm like somewhat not poor so they're
better golfers than me you got to throw
it in like that
my next essential is the oil Eliminator
Kiehl's moisturizer because my t-zone
tends to get oily so I have to eliminate
the oil with my trusty Kiehl's oil
eliminate growing up a little kid in New
Orleans
you just used like Jergens and you went
from the top of your head to the bottom
of your feet and that was your
moisturizer game but once you get older
and like you start going to college and
you get a girlfriend and they teach you
like shampoo and conditioner it's
different than soap like you can't take
the Dove and just go dub dub dub dub dub
you have to go dubbed of shampoo
conditioner facial wash it's four
different things just to wash one person
so you can't go kids kids kids cut
skills you have to go oil eliminator
kills then you have to go body keels so
they have many different products for
many different things to serve you in
many different ways that's word up these
are my trusty SoulCycle of choice yes
it's true I like to listen to rhythmic
music and lift weights while I ride
bikes for long distances against young
women yes we shootin Falcon Winter
Soldier now in Atlanta so you have a lot
of different cycling places so you have
the cycling places in Buckhead where you
have like a lot of young women with
ponytails that are scream and very angry
on their bikes or you can go to the
cycling place in Decatur where there are
a lot of young angry people who yell and
twerk on bikes or you go to Midtown
where is just a bunch of nice people
that ride bikes no one's yelling no
one's throwing stuff everyone's sweating
I started smoking cigars I would say it
was 2005 I had just finished a movie and
I was starting to play golf and to look
cool
somebody gave me a cigar and I actually
really liked it and then I bought my
first cigar smoke that then I went to
Cuba I mean I didn't I mean I went but I
didn't go like they can't the federal
government can't get me for that right
good so I went to Cuba and I had some
ham roll cigars then I went to Nicaragua
has some cigars didn't Dominican
Republik has some cigars there and I
started learning the different
characteristics of the different regions
so then I just fell in love with
Nicaragua mmm it's the Pacific so you
have milder temperatures you have more
wind off the Pacific you have mountain
ranges so when the air mixes just right
you get a hearty early you get thicker
veins so you get less of an earthy or
harsh taste like on the East Coast but
you get more of a mild caramel
smoothness on the west coast
Nicaragua yes yes
did you just pet him on the head you
just yes
growing up in New Orleans it's like
saints or nothing I always go to the
games Michael Thomas craters while
receiving the league right now shutting
it down
oh I'm steady that's what we do a man
went to Florida came back with 15 more
pounds of muscle nasty come on man come
on you can't mess with it you can't come
mara coming out the back here you can't
mess with it there's gonna be our year
the last two years have been shaky you
know so we have we put out petitions for
the referees to spend some time in New
Orleans on vacation for free but there's
gonna be a good season I think we need
one more piece we need like a you know
like a Brandon cooked me somebody to
take the top off we got somebody to take
the top off we back up to 45 points
again off top Oh Zimmer's is a
neighborhood place in Gentilly the seven
war I grew up three blocks from there
and I've been going there since I was
three years old it's a neighborhood
plate they catch fresh seafood every
morning they come and they make fresh
sandwiches with the seafood so what you
do is get you a half shrimp po-boy dress
with pickles no cheese - a hot sauce get
you one turkey neck get you one we have
this thing called the Delaware punch
it's telling nowhere else on the world
it's not from Delaware I went to
Delaware to see it's not there
this Delaware punch get that go to the
lakefront put your tailgate down sit in
the back of your truck and live you the
best money I do that once a week that
might substitute to Delaware punch with
a house daiquiri it just it all depends
on what the day look like
I'm an avid admirer of art I feel like
you know if you go through the annals of
history every moment in time is kind of
outlined by the art that's created so I
love going to museums it's the clearest
form of expression it can be daunting it
can be riveting or it can be something
that's so simple that it informs
everything around you like every time I
create a character for a movie I pick a
song and I pick a piece of art that kind
of represents the social makeup of that
character so I tend to go to museums
often and aquariums
like aquariums the three best aquariums
in America San Diego Atlanta and New
Orleans hands down hands down go hold it
down man keep the waves fresh all day
because I got like five different grains
of hair on my head so Amman tarik has
got my cut down to a science
literally if I'm within a one-hour
flight of Atlanta I will fly to Atlanta
for my dude to cut my hair my man -
Rico's it down how long cutting my hair
sir thank you I don't get my hair done
it's been I mean I've been with Terry
for like 12 13 years now
not in the phase fresh always on deck
I'm Anthony Mackie thanks guys for
checking out my essentials I'll see you
as Emma's shrimp po-boy dress extra
pickles - AHA songs